мені би хотілося після такого красивого
гладенького звіту пана міністра
запитатися А що він робив 112 днів перед
вторгненням він уже був міністром А я
нагадаю 28 січня 22-го року всією ложі
уряду він говорив що це не вторгнення а
паніка в нашій голові і грошей на армію
достатньо і блокував виділення 50 млрд
грн на потреби збройних сил України 22
лютого 22-го року в ефірі телебачення
пане резніков говорить про відсутність
ударного угрупування на півночі зокрема
з Білорусі забуваючи що в цей же ж час у
нас міністр оборони Білорусі красиво був
на навчаннях в Україні тому я мушу
сказати що оці всі яйця по 17 куртки
блокування постачання виробництва Дронів
і БПЛА - це лише квіточки із порівняні
із злочинною цинічною і наглою не
підготовкою до вторгнення коли по суті
робилося абсолютно все щоб Україна не
вистояла